hey guys how's it going so let's go
through this network test together shall
we
I've played through this area so many
times now I've been lucky enough to get
a chance at pretty much every iteration
of this demo and I think I've come up
with some good talking points some of
these things were going to talk about
today our little secrets that I found
after playing for so long and some of
them are just really important changes
for the game as a whole but mostly this
is a chance to talk about Dark Souls 3
with the 9 hours of footage I managed to
record so let's get into it after you
choose your starting character you spawn
into this room and behind you is an
ornament that looks suspiciously like
the Lord vessel from Dark Souls 1
resting upon it is one of those swords
that you find within a bonfire the same
sword that's used in the rumored
sacrifice bonfire mechanic that we
haven't seen in action yet if you're not
familiar with the Lord vessel it was
this item in Dark Souls 1 that stored
the souls of really really powerful
Lords and unlocked the gate to the final
boss and having it also allowed you to
walk between bonfires I was thinking in
Dark Souls 3 you're able to warp it
between bonfires from the very start
according to Miyazaki so maybe this
signifies that as we progress down this
Lane way take a close look at these
hollows off to the left and right the
first thing that struck me was that in
this game they're gray not brown or
green like in previous games but what's
most interesting about them is that
they're praying and that they pray to
two specific things they pray to the
trees and they pray to the Dragons now
the Dragons I'm pretty sure are the
stone dragons from Dark Souls 1 whatever
that implies we'll get to later and the
trees are interesting too because they
have other hollows woven and grown into
them so what are the implications of
this why is there this powerful gray
ashen theme throughout the entire game
and why the hollows praying to trees and
stone dragons
well once gray arch trees and stone
dragons was all that there was this was
the age of ancients where everything was
gray and lifeless and nothing lived then
there was the age of fire and there was
an age of darkness that always
threatened it these undead came
exist within this disparity they were
creatures that were unable to die and
were destined to go Hollow and despair
my intuition tells me that these hollows
here might be praying for some return to
this gray age where nothing lived and
nothing died and we mentioned before how
there are hollows woven into the trees
that they're praying to and that's not
the first time that we've seen that kind
of rebirth the Giants in Dark Souls 2
they turned into trees and grew that way
perhaps the hollows here are praying and
hoping for some kind of rebirth in that
kind of vein but it's really bizarre
there's no real clear answer right now
but it awakens that curiosity we have
and it makes us ask what part of the
dark souls timeline are we in right now
and the fact that it awakens that
curiosity at all that's what's important
as we get into this next area you've got
to ask yourself like dem and all these
hollows have to do all day is sit around
and there's so many perfectly good
chairs in this area why isn't anyone
sitting down but why are there so many
chairs here what's interesting is that
all these chairs are pointed towards the
dragon and what I get from this is that
they're there for a reason
maybe when these dragons landed or died
it looks like the inhabitants of the
castle pulled out a bunch of chairs from
inside and just sat watching the dragon
as it flaked away as they hollowed they
probably abandoned those chairs and got
down on their knees instead that's my
take on it anyway as we killed these
enemies take a look at the blood
splatter effect
it's definitely reminiscent of
blood-borne isn't it and that blood
splatter it's a great effect it's a
welcome one and it is nice that it's a
little bit tuned down you don't become
drenched in blood like you do in
blood-borne but to me it's an indicator
that this game is clearly running on an
appropriation of Blood Bones
engine and man this engine feels good I
love it you have that tight control over
your character like you do in
blood-borne yet they've tweaked it so
that attacks feel segmented and
controlled in that traditional Souls way
in blood-borne they were more flowing
and ferocious people are commenting that
the guy
feels too fast and I think when you
think about it being too fast it's worth
remembering that characters felt really
fast in this demo because equipment
burden isn't a thing yet and so we've
yet to see what a character really feels
like when they're burdened down by plate
and weapons in the network test there
were four tombstones that you could
offer a flame to this one reads grave of
the nameless retainer raised his sword
for the Lord of cinder each one seems to
tell the lore of someone who died here
in this spot if I'm not mistaken this
one for example explains a simple
retainers grave and I'll bring up the
rest as we get to them the others are a
bit more interesting in one of the
presentations I attended I got to see
Miyazaki present and he said that it was
his favorite little touch to add a giant
fire-breathing dragon to the first level
and as usual he delivers on that one
thing you might not have known is that
you can actually kill this dragon with
the mage class it requires you to keep
drinking your ash test flasks and
replenish your Manor and you know that
just made me remember like I really like
how mana actually feels like a resource
in this game unlike having spell charges
in previous souls games when you kill
the dragon you get 27 K souls which was
fantastic in a demo where you couldn't
use souls but you know seriously I think
it's gonna be amazing if you can kill
that dragon early in the game in Dark
Souls 3 because 27 K at this point in
the game that's a ridiculous amount
considering this is one of the early
levels if you run through the fire
before or after it lands it allows you
to bypass the path to the side and you
can go under the dragon and avoid
fighting a mob of enemies but it's not
really a shortcut it's more like an
alternate path you face this spear
wielding soldier instead and you get a
few extra items for your trouble one
thing about taking this alternate path
is that when you exit the room like I'm
doing here you can expect to get
ambushed
there are hollows hiding on the left and
right of this door that aggro as soon as
you walk past them which perfectly
interrupts your knight fight it's
interesting though if you walk perfectly
down the middle of the path they don't
aggro I was pretty impressed with the
ambush timings in this game there are a
lot of thief type hollows that will leap
at you with star
dueling accuracy which really motivates
you to keep the shield up at all times
and check all those corners I kept
forgetting about this guy for example
and his attacks are pretty punishing and
like even if you know he's coming at you
they hone in on you so it's quite hard
to dodge it even in subsequent
playthroughs and halfway through this
demo I remembered that embers are a
thing they weren't in previous versions
if you consume an ember it grants you a
large bonus to your maximum health it
restores all your health and it also
opens you up to invading summoning and
being invaded your character has his or
her ember restored and the edges of your
clothing become singed
I love the effect every game has
something like this but this ember
combines a lot of things from previous
games they actually retained that
humanity shape from previous games which
is odd because our character doesn't
even appear to have a physical hollow
state you know there's gonna be an
answer to that question like why aren't
we hollow and why are we restoring our
em bar I'd even go as far as to say is
we might not be a chosen undead in this
game
halfway through the stage you'll come
across this group of hollows who are
praying to a tree on the top of a roof
but then one of them stands and walks
towards you slowly and then
this guy's intimidating and he's really
disorienting the first time you fight
him it's quite easy to fight him if you
manage to stand behind it but the trick
is just that staying behind it when you
first fight him it's hard to figure out
which part is his head which part is his
hand which part is attacking you and
staying behind it is tough until you
figure that out
you can actually kill this guy quickly
before he becomes a black mats but few
new players will figure this out first
try at this point you can overlook most
of the stage and it's here that you
realize how vertically they've designed
this area the path splits here and it
offers three different directions
different enemies to face but only one
destination down the fastest and most
suicidal way down is to drop off this
roof to the courtyard below but very few
people will do this the ladder is the
most logical option and this right here
is one of my favorite points in the demo
from a design perspective like pretend
you're coming down this ladder right now
you might have seen that hollow over
there right but it doesn't even look
like he's facing you so if you did see
him you've probably discounted him as
not being a threat and right next to
this ladder is a doorway and this
doorway takes you on the longest path to
the boss
with the most enemies and dead ends and
risks of dying but you don't know that
and then you get hit by this arrow you
might even realize that this arrow goes
straight through the room here
so naturally you'll feel like you're
endangered from some sort of sniper
you'll turn around and go and kill the
guy shooting you and then another guy
will shoot you so you'll go and kill him
then you get ambushed and it's like a
trail of breadcrumbs
leading you towards the most logical
option because going down this really
long ladder is the fastest way to the
shortcut but if you did decide to go
through this doorway then you're in for
a longer path and it has more dead ends
and more difficult enemies hidden at the
bottom of these stairs is the dungeon
cell key which unlocks an optional mini
boss type enemy as well as another law
stone to honor and shadowy retreats fear
the sun's temptations and the winged
executioner you could even argue that
the wing its executioner is this fat
Knight who will be your next opponent he
has an executioner's axe
and he has these little wing like
protrusions on his back after all but
basically he's BOSU so from berserk he's
likely going to be your most difficult
enemy so far before you unlock the
shortcut he has a few tricks up his
sleeve for some reason he's not the kind
of enemy you expect to cast magic but he
does and he also has this charged spin
attack that you're gonna want to look
out for which can easily clip you on its
last swing it's also interesting that
he's wearing blue I was watching a let's
play by another uploader called Hellkite
Drake and he mentioned that the blue
color could represent how he's from a
different army and he might be opposed
to all these Knights in the red
additionally he's an executioner
standing in a courtyard full of headless
Knights so those two things could be
related as well although you could
easily make the argument to the contrary
I mean if he's from a different faction
why are the other red knights just
letting him live and why hadn't they
killed him before they all went Hollow
and if he is an executioner why are
their statues holding their heads in
their hands later on that would imply
that the statues were crafted before
everyone got their heads cut off and
yeah there's a few things that don't
match up here but that decapitation
theme it becomes really strong towards
the end of the demo with more and more
statues depicting it as well as lots of
headless Knights throughout the place
just before the boss you come across
this area with a lot of knights and one
of them is even a red eye Knight which
is a bit of a Demon Souls throwback when
I fight all these guys I use a lot of
weapon arts and it really made me feel
like weapon arts are a great way to use
mana you know when you use a spell it's
situational and in the same way when you
use a weapon art which consumes manner
it also feels situational you commonly
use it to break an opponent's guard or
to fling them up into the air and it's
just another tool you can use to take
out really powerful enemies this red eye
Knight is guarding a law note which
reads this exile was traced from his
homeland and haunted by a black son in
one of the cinematic trailers you would
have seen these hags or pilgrims as
they're called travelling across the
frozen wasteland with these shells on
their back now in the courtyard outside
the boss room you can see them here as
well
they're all trying to climb over the
fence or make their way towards the
actual Cathedral it almost looked like
some flash event occurred where they all
became petrified at the same time it's
quite strange before we fight the boss
let's go and fight the ice Knight do you
guys remember that key I mentioned
before you can use it to unlock a cell
door far below the second bonfire this
takes you down to the ice Knight and
this dude is tough he's fast he's
aggressive his mobile and it takes
roughly 20 hits to kill him with a light
weapon on top of all of that
if you stand close to him or get hit by
his weapon then it'll cause this
frostbite meter to build up and if this
frostbite meter reaches full then you're
considered frostbitten for roughly 10
seconds or so and you won't be able to
regenerate stamina nearly as fast so in
most cases if you get frostbitten then
that's pretty much instant death as you
won't be able to block or dodge as
effectively and this guy is so
aggressive that that means you're gonna
die I expect the frostbite effect to be
some sort of weapon enchantment or buff
that you can apply since it looks like
it's a part of his weapon if you do
manage to kill him it might take you a
couple of tries it allows you to read
the last law note which reads died in
solitude may his soul find its way back
to the frigid Valley this is the final
bit of proof that these graves refer to
the hollowed creatures that reside near
them so uh at the end of one of the
network test periods I decided I've kind
of done everything I might try to
speedrun this because I've played it so
much so on this character I managed to
get to the final boss and kill her in
three minutes and 45 seconds from the
very start of the game and this shows
that it's still possible to speedrun
even though enemies do try to get in
your way more often than in previous
games but as long as you know where
you're going you can get there fast the
boss herself is pretty special
her moveset is mesmerizing and it's
difficult to predict and they've clearly
made her but really defined so it
distracts players it's really clever the
camera also zooms out during the fight
just like in blood-borne so it's a bit
easier to manage and I love how the
cathedral just
becomes more and more on fire as this
fight continues but yeah that's pretty
much it guys like if you'd like to
dislike if you didn't and before you go
I'd really appreciate if you headed over
to Judas's channel Jude has helped me
out with some other rendering settings
for this video and as a result you
should notice it looking a little bit
crisper and not as bad as YouTube
usually makes it so yeah go check him
out he made a really good video on all
the new changes in Dark Souls 3 and it
goes into a lot of detail so enjoy and
thanks for watching guys